Hey youtubers it’s Charlie.
Yesterday in my Episode 5 review I asked you
all to submit questions about WTF Crasters,
Sansa, Arya and The Hound and everything else.
So I picked 10 of them to answer in this video
with 1 bonus question.
I also have an epic thank you to deliver.
As I’m posting this video I officially just
hit 200,000 subscribers.
Thank you everyone for being so awesome.
I’ll try to do a special announcement video
this week for all the new stuff I’m working
on.
Also, high fives to Shelly Summers and Matt
Dave, you guys are the random winners from
this week’s giveaway.
You win $20 Amazon giftcards.
I’ll contact you on your channels for details.
Next round starts after episode 6.
If you’re just finding me for the first
time be sure to subscribe to get that video.
So let’s answer some questions, you guys
had a lot of good ones this week.
Careful for spoilers from the episode if you
haven’t seen it yet.
Here we go.
Question 1 - Amour Asks Why did Locke want
Bran, what was he going to do with him?
If you remember all the way back to the last
time we saw Theon and Ramsay Snow at the Dreadfort.
They told Roose that Bran and Rickon were
still alive.
Right now Roose is supposed to rule in the
North.
But as long as the Stark children are still
alive, people could rally support behind them.
So Roose sent Locke to capture them so they
could prevent any challenges to their rule.
He was never going to kill him.
Just lock him up like Theon in the Dreadfort.
Roose isn’t as vicious as Ramsay, but they
would still have been prisoners.
Question 2 - Jessica asks Is Arya’s Direwolf
Nymeria still alive?
And is she gonna be back in the story?﻿
Nymeria is still alive, but George RR Martin
hasn’t said one way or the other as to a
reunion with Arya.
The show has been changing a lot of things,
but until it’s confirmed, just assume that
Nymeria is running wild between the Riverlands
and Winterfell.
Question 3 - Emily Whittle asks How long do
you think Arya and the Hound will stay together?
(mention needle stabbing)
They really did teas us with Arya’s prayer
and her trying to stab him with Needle.
I think it says a lot that the blade didn’t
penetrate his armor.
I think it’s Dave and Dan letting us know
that they’ll be together for a while.
I’m all in favor of them staying together
all season, but clearly things can’t go
on like they are now.
She definitely hates him and there’s no
way their story is going to get a happy ending
all nice and clean.
I’m just waiting for the rug to get yanked
out from under them in the last couple of
episodes.
For all the book readers out there too, I
personally wouldn’t flip out if they changed
the book plot a lot and did something crazy.
Just like with the White Walkers last week.
Question 4 - Hombrezzz asks What do you think
will happen to Kings Landing because of their
debts?﻿
After I made my review video I saw Mark Gatiss
was in the teaser for episode 6, he’s going
to answer your question.
I think the Bank is going to threaten to fund
Stannis unless the Throne can repay their
debt.
Remember a Lannister always pays his debts.
And right now it looks like the Tyrells are
their only option.
So a bunch of stuff could happen.
They could find a way to discredit Mace Tyrell
and Margaery and use that as an excuse to
seize their assets, or the Tyrells could agree
to pay the crown’s debt in exchange for
a seat on the Small Council.
Question 5 - Genesis This asks How come Cercei
was so civil towards Margaery?
I think there’s a couple things going on
in that situation.
First she’s still completely mentally and
emotionally fried from Joffrey’s death.
And she’s reconciling the reality of his
craziness.
Remember how she talked about how he shocked
her?
So she doesn’t have the energy to hate right
now.
She’s just thinking about Tommen’s future.
Which leads to the second big reason she’s
being nice.
She wants Tommen to stay pure like he is now.
And she knows that he needs more positive
influences in his life.
Even though according to Littlefinger everyone
in King’s Landing is a liar.
So she’s trying to appeal to Margaery’s
sense of goodness.
Cersei definitely knows what Margaery is capable
of, but given the chance I think Margaery
is a good person.
Remember how shocked she was when Lady Olenna
explained how she killed Joffrey?
With the help of Littlefinger and Ser Dontos
of course.
Question 6 - Yughandhar asks when will we
see Gendry and Yara Greyjoy again?
A lot of you guys have asked me about Gendry
and I’m happy to say he’s still alive.
The show wouldn’t just forget about him
after he rowed away from Dragonstone.
It’s possible that they could combine the
Yara Ironborn story with Gendry’s escape.
There both on the right side of Westeros.
Gendry was originally supposed to row his
way to King’s Landing, but I don’t think
he’ll make it there.
If he runs into Yara and ends up helping them
out, they’ll probably run into Theon and
Ramsay Snow eventually.
Right now that feels like where they’re
taking things.
But Gendry could always run into Arya again.
She’s also headed in an easterly direction.
Either way, Gendry will be back.
We just don’t know which episode yet.
Question 7 - Stephanie Herman (no avatar)
asks Do you think that next season will get
into Winds of Winter stuff because the show
is moving so fast?
No I don’t think so.
There’s still a ton of Dance With Dragons
stuff I haven’t seen yet.
They really have slowed the pace of the story
down.
And think about how short some of Daenerys’
scenes have been.
She was barely in this episode.
What I do think will happen is that we’ll
get more side tracked white walker type scenes.
Like Bran at Crasters.
Some of the Directors have already said they
expect more big deviations to come up as the
show gets further along.
So don’t plan on seeing any Winds of Winter
stuff till Season 6 at the earliest.
Remember, they’re shooting for 8 seasons.
Question 8 - Lexyvil what was the reason for
the Craster’s house plot with Bran, Locke
and Jon Snow?
I think a lot of things were going on there.
First you have Locke, a character that wasn’t
in the books.
Then you have Bran, who really isn’t even
in the story.
The whole Bran going to find the Weirwood
Tree is part of Dance With Dragons.
So they did a Theon thing where they add extra
story to fill the gaps in the timeline.
Plus they also had Burn Gorman’s character
and the Night’s Watch Revolt plot they had
to tie up.
So the whole Craster’s House battle was
a way to clean everything up with a nice bow
on top.
Now Bran is back on track, the revolt has
been put down and Jon Snow can worry about
the impending Wildling Attack and Locke a
character not in the original story is taken
care of.
So think of Crasters as a filler story for
a period of time that the books didn’t really
cover.
Remember sometimes characters don’t appear
in every book.
So the show has to deal with that.
Question 9 - RyanBirds asks will ever see
the Brotherhood without Banners again?
(Brienne)
The Brotherhood is still in the Riverlands
near the Crossroads.
They haven’t left.
And Brienne is headed in that direction with
Podrick looking for Sansa.
So if anyone runs into them it will be her.
I know everyone keeps asking me about Lady
Stoneheart.
There has been no indication that she’s
going to be on the show.
So I don’t want to talk about her too soon.
But just be careful how you mention her in
the comments for people who haven’t read
the books.
Make sure to post spoiler warnings.
Question 10 - Peter Rubin asks How will Braavos
come into the show?
I think that Mark Gatiss will be the first
real introduction.
Although the Bank has branches in all the
kingdoms of the world.
It’s central office is just located in Braavos.
As for that scene of the Titan from the trailers.
I don’t think they’d put something from
the end of the season in the trailer.
So I’m guessing Stannis or Ser Davos will
go there to get more money.
There are scenes from the trailers with them
on a ship together.
And they haven’t left Dragonstone yet.
Bonus Question Curtis Gerdes (no avatar) asks
do you think Daenerys will end up riding one
of her Dragons eventually?
I would be super bummed if they didn’t.
They’ve been teasing it enough.
Because a scene like that would such a huge
payoff, I would bet they save it for the finale.
If they end up doing it.
So don’t expect to see that until episode
10.
Remember how that final shot in season 3 was
of all those people lifting her into the air.
Don’t you think a perfect way to visually
call back to that would be for Drogon to literally
lift her into the air.
And then bam, slam to black for another year
until season 5 comes.
That’s just my opinion.
I think that would be the perfect way to end
season 4.
So thank you so much everyone for sending
me questions.
And thank you for just being awesome in general.
Like I said I’ll try to make an announcement
video for all the new stuff I’m working
on right now.
My next bonus video will be for Braavos.
I’ll just talk about the culture and organizations
like the Faceless Ones and the Iron Bank.
Be sure to subscribe to get it if you’re
finding me for the first time!
Right now click here for my review of the
episode and click here to learn more about
the first war with the White Walkers and the
building of the Wall.
See you guys tomorrow.
Now I need to give out 200,000 high fives.
So I’ll just leave this up for a second.